l'ivoire sont pris pour des voleurs et
ça c'est insupportable quoi moi qui ai
connu l'époque où on avait de bons liens
avec les restantes dans l'ensemble là
les gens il nous conseille vraiment
comme des voix là il faut vraiment
vérifié que on a bien accepté la course
mettez vous demander une carte
d'identité arrive j'en sais rien quoi à
l'océanie livreur à vélo et là il est
10h45 échange de prendre ma première
course avec vous à le bruiteur là y'a
plus de commandes donc je pense qu'on va
se rapprocher du centre au niveau de la
gare qui va faire aujourd'hui
j'espère que je vais en faire beaucoup
mais c'est avec plein de courses
derosa a commencé un an avant que
j'arrive en france et a eu plusieurs
étapes en fait d'un haut niveau des
rémunérations au niveau du les points
c'est ce client tout ça et j'ai vu j'ai
pu suivre toute l'évolution l époque moi
je faisais 11 ans mini tous les jours à
la défense et
j'étais comme un drogué de ça je faisais
partie de beaucoup de livres qui étaient
des droits y en avait plus à s'arrêter à
paris il y avait vraiment beaucoup
d'argent à faire les voix rappelé à
l'époque la cash machine
c'est pas d'essai pas les images des
gens qui faisait du 5-6 1000 par mois
après faut travailler du matin au soir
mais c'est passé pas des légendes moi
j'ai vraiment vu de mes propres yeux
c'est le moment où la plateforme art il
n'y a pas beaucoup de commandes donc il
faut avoir des erreurs donc on les paye
bien à l'heure parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de courses et après aujourd'hui on est
dans une phase où il ya beaucoup de
livres il y avait beaucoup de joueurs
qui postulent et qui n'arrive pas en
fait à travailler sur la plateforme et
en même temps il ya beaucoup de
commandes pas ça j'ai eu un carton au
milieu c'est ce que l'on dit c'est
beaucoup
ah oui oui assurément ben en fait c'est
compliqué coire est quelque chose de
lisse et moi je regarde chaque semaine
en brut j'essaie d'être à 70 euros
ouais chaque chaque jour en fait mais
c'est pas énorme zone 10 euros saint lys
et les jours où je travaille pas les
soirées les jours je travaille les soirs
la rémunération aujourd'hui elle est
basée sur la distance sur
le nombre d' acceptation plus tôt le
nombre de refus de la course selon le
secteur si c'est un secteur difficile et
aura je pense que le prix de la cause
forcément il va augmenter pour que les
gens acceptent brut là c'est très calme
franchement la 4e course
la roche il est 21h et regarder devant
que moi j'attends j'attends de voir ce à
quoi franchement si je pouvais récupérer
une commande comme ça à chaque fois je
récupère des commandes du boeing du
magot enfin bon moi j'aime pas ça tout à
fait récupéré ça mais c'est quoi la
moyenne des baux
à moyenne doit être 0,25 à 25 centimes
je sais pas jamais donc on va voir à
pourvoir sur cinq six courses peut-être
à l'époque où nous proposer
systématiquement avoir des peut-être des
fois des choses à manger et c'est donc
aujourd'hui on est vraiment considéré
comme un simple numéro défaut ne nous
répondent même pas les clients c'est
pareil les fois ils ne veulent même plus
nous voir et nous disent même plus
bonjour on a plus de pourboire voilà
donc même quand il pleut c'est très rare
qu'on ait des pouvoirs donc tout ça
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui les dérives
ça peut être aussi des dérives au niveau
de la distance parce qu'à l'époque on
avait des courses qui était maximum 3 km
aujourd'hui pour des collègues scooters
3 km c'est le milieu syndical quoi ils
font des courses enormissime de 7km quoi
c'est devenu une norme en fait
aujourd'hui
travailleurs
oui alors après je n'ai pas parlé mais
effectivement on peut parler de tous les
sans papiers qui représente en tout cas
sûrement secteur il n'a pas tant que ça
mais un à 30% facile au moins au moins
dans les groupes sur les réseaux sociaux
on avait à l'époque des groupes
d'entr'aide on pouvait poser des
questions on avait des discours x ou y
sur le métier de coursiers livreurs des
astuces aujourd'hui quand vous allez sur
ces groupes sur facebook twitter ou
autres n'importe quoi télégramme ce ne
sont que des annonces pour louer des
comptes à des sans-papiers à 100 euros
200 euros la semaine donc c'est vrai que
c'est devenu un petit peu une horreur
pour ses pensées personnes là
il faut trouver des solutions
aujourd'hui comme moi je n'aime pas en
fait être enfermé j'aime faire du vélo
j'aime faire du sport c'est vrai que
c'est une solution trier medal même si
j'aimerais pas être payés plus après
pour les personnes qui sont sans papiers
qui n'ont pas de ressources oui ça c'est
une autre histoire le problème c'est que
ça tire effectivement les prix vers le
bas mes poils ils ont pas choix nous on
devrait avoir un statut adapté à nous on
ne va pas pouvoir accepter des courses
qui sont un prix trop bas
ah ouais à ses avocats ça marche très
bien ici c'est très bien et en journée
le sont parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
blindé de monde moi je suis un peu
nostalgique de cette époque
vraiment on avait un être humain qu'on
connaissait au bout du téléphone qui
s'occupait vraiment du secteur je suis
nostalgique de cette période où vraiment
se retrouver entre collègues ont mangé
ensemble on s'entre aider on avait un
groupe sur lequel on communiqué sauf
deux personnes à la défense tout le
monde était en vélo je suis vraiment
nostalgique de cette cette phase là mais
après ça fait un peu entre guillemets
vieux con mais bon c'est l'évolution
c'est comme ça je pense qu'il faut vivre
avec son temps
alors on va s'en est voilà donc la fin
de service et jeunes livrés dans cette
magnifique tour juste ici
parce que sympathique moi il n'y a pas
beaucoup de courses c'est dommage mais
bon
toujours des petites histoires drôles
des gens à voir et puis on termine avec
une vue quand même assez magnifique à
sherbrooke
[Musique]